tornadoes also destroyed at least 20
homes and left people injured in Smith
station that's about 20 miles east of
Beauregard near the Georgia State Line
Omar Villafranca is one of the hardest
hit areas there with the latest Omar
good morning to you
we are here in Smith station and there's
an elementary school nearby us a couple
homes all of them have some sort of
damage good news though there are no
fatalities here but the damage is pretty
devastating let me walk you through kind
of what we're seeing here piece of a
home right here but when you step over
here this is about a five-story pine
tree that was snapped in half behind us
this is where that damage came from from
this home over here there's a tree
that's inside good news is we understand
that nobody was seriously injured in
this home interesting of note the mayor
of Smith station a man by the name of
Fred Bubba Copeland told us while he was
walking on this street after the storm
he actually heard some women who were
calling for help he was able to go into
that home clear some debris get them to
safety they were injured but not
seriously and just a little bit more
about the power of this storm but what
we're learning when it touched down and
debris started flying that was actually
picked up on radar and the debris field
from what we understand was pretty wide
but that debris also went as much as
20,000 feet up in the air about three
and a half miles also we want to show
you this there was a billboard that was
here in Smith station but after the
storm blew through it wound up about 20
miles away over the state line in
Hamilton Georgia also trees weren't the
only ones that were damaged there was
also power lines and also cell phone
towers this one here ripped down
basically just became a piece of flying
metal what's interesting also is there
were about 40 people at a hospital they
were injured that number could go up
because now that the Sun is starting to
come up the search-and-rescue missions
will continue
bianna Omar thank you